C'est une manière vraiment très équilibrée et précise d'introduire la conception de la providence.
La providence est quelque part définie par sa relation ou par comparaison avec la doctrine de la création.
D'une manière générale, lorsqu'on parle de la création, c'est Dieu qui amène à l'existence toutes les choses qui n'existaient pas.
C'est par les décrets de Dieu, c'est par sa parole puissante que Dieu va tout créer.
Et même si on peut percevoir quelque part déjà au niveau des providences, même dans l'ordre des choses qu'il a créées.
Donc on a des lois de fonctionnement dans les systèmes qu'on a dans notre corps, les systèmes qu'on voit dans les mondes,
qui sont déjà des indices de la providence, même si Dieu a déjà créé ces choses avec ces mêmes systèmes ou ces mêmes lois.
Mais ce qui est intéressant, c'est que la Bible insiste pour qu'on voit l'acte de la création de Dieu comme un acte fini et conclu.
Et donc Dieu a cessé d'écrire toutes les choses, mais Dieu continue actif dans la manière dont il est directement impliqué dans les soutiens ou la maintenance de toutes ces choses.
Car même les systèmes qui fonctionnent, les systèmes de notre raisonnement qui ont pensé être complètement livrés à nous-mêmes,
même les systèmes respiratoires, toute la circulation sanguine, même l'équilibre magnétique de l'univers entre les planètes, etc.
Toutes ces choses sont subsistantes en lui, en Christ, en Christ qui soutient toutes les choses par sa parole puissante.
Mais c'est intéressant, à la création, on est en train de nous rappeler que Dieu a amené à existence toutes choses.
Et dans la providence, on est plutôt en train de considérer la maintenance, la continuité des choses, les soutiens et même la gouvernance de Dieu sur toutes choses.
Donc ça, c'est juste une définition introductoire.
On a considéré pourquoi dans certains enseignements, on considère d'abord la création de l'homme en tant qu'image des dieux avant la providence,
et pourquoi dans d'autres cas, on va considérer d'abord la providence avant l'homme.
Et la distinction, elle est tout simplement, nous, on est en train de faire après l'image des dieux dans l'homme.
Pourquoi ? Car on a voulu plutôt honorer l'apexe ou les sommets de la création comme en étant l'homme lui-même.
Et aussi, pour considérer une conception plus large de la providence.
Dans quel sens ?
Quand on considère d'abord la providence avant l'homme, on veut aussi honorer l'homme comme les sommets de la création,
car Dieu a même établi des systèmes, des provisions dans la création avant que l'homme puisse arriver.
Donc il y avait déjà les plantes, les fruits, etc.
Toutes les choses nécessaires pour que lorsqu'il l'homme soit créé, il ait déjà tout un univers à son service, pour qu'il ait de la provision.
Donc Dieu a déjà établi la providence avant même que l'homme soit créé, afin que l'homme puisse aussi avoir sa provision.
Mais la providence, elle ne s'arrête pas à nouveau dans ce système de provision envers l'homme.
La providence, elle va s'engager à l'accomplissement.
C'est un Dieu qui va mener à terme, par son contrôle direct de toutes les choses qui se passent dans l'existence,
pour mener à terme son décret éternel.
On sait très bien comment on a étudié les décrets éternels des dieux.
Dieu n'a qu'un plan A, c'est un plan parfait, et un plan qui a pour but centre et qui culmine dans l'évangile
et dans l'humanité restaurée et glorifiée avec Christ à la gloire.
Donc Dieu a ça comme plan A.
Toutes les autres choses tournent autour de ça.
Mais c'est intéressant de remarquer que quand on pense à la providence,
on est en train de penser à la manière dont Dieu lui-même est en train de gouverner l'histoire
pour mener à terme son plan et ses décrets éternels.
Donc Dieu planifie toutes les choses parfaitement.
Dieu a créé toutes les choses et Dieu est impliqué dans la gouvernance
et dans la maintenance de toute l'histoire afin de conduire toutes les choses à ses fins glorieuses.
Et donc par là, on a déjà considéré dans l'ordre des doctrines qu'on est en train de considérer,
bien sûr les écritures, Dieu, les décrets, la création,
et ensuite on est en train de considérer la providence.
Et donc la providence, elle parle d'une activité continuelle des dieux.
Même si les termes, l'expression providence à avoir avec la conception des prévoyances,
littéralement parlant, cela veut non seulement mettre une emphase sur ce qu'on appelle
la capacité des dieux de voir en avant ce qui va se passer,
car là on est plutôt en train de parler de la préscience des dieux,
mais c'est plutôt une capacité des dieux de s'assurer que tout ce qu'il est en train de prévoir,
tout ce qu'il a décrété, qu'il a planifié, il va conduire.
Donc ça ne parle pas d'un dieu qui voit les choses en avance de manière passive.
C'est un dieu qui va mener les choses qu'il a prévues,
qui ont été fondées sur sa souveraineté et qu'il va conduire les choses.
Donc ça va au-delà de sa capacité de voir des choses,
ça va confirmer qu'il est fondément des dieux,
qu'il a pour capacité de voir en avance,
c'est notamment la manière dont il assure qu'il conduira l'univers
et chaque atome et chaque détail
pour que ce qu'il a vu d'avance, qu'il a planifié d'avance,
se passe et arrive.
Donc là on n'est plus dans l'échange tout simplement de la préscience des dieux
comme en attribut de son nominiscence,
on est plutôt dans cette maintenance de l'univers
sous l'orientation divine de manière très active.
On a considéré aussi la pertinence d'étudier ces thèmes,
aujourd'hui particulièrement,
on a vu que dans plusieurs étapes différentes de l'histoire de l'Église,
c'était nécessaire de traiter quelques doctrines
qui ont été plus importantes dans certaines saisons
car elles étaient plus défiées.
Les premiers siècles, la Trinité ou la Christologie,
la double nature du Christ qui a été attaquée
et qui a été très bien défendue.
Plus tard dans la réforme, la justification par la foi
et plus récemment, on dirait depuis les deux grandes guerres mondiales
avec toute la déception, avec toutes les révolutions industrielles
et notamment aujourd'hui avec les développements
et la popularisation de la mentalité naturaliste, scientifique
qui réduit toutes les choses à la matière
et qui met en question tout ce qui est surnaturel
et qui est très fermé à une participation,
une intervention divine dans l'histoire.
Nous sommes à nouveau devant la pertinence,
l'une des pertinences les plus importantes
à propos de la connaissance du peuple des dieux,
de la doctrine de la providence,
pour qu'on puisse être bien entraîné à répondre,
à présenter les raisons de notre espérance,
à répondre à des questions qui se portent contre cette doctrine.
Donc par exemple, ils vont dire,
mais comment un Dieu bon et tout-puissant
pourrait être justifié comme un Éteint au contrôle
si nous voyons par exemple ces guerres qui continuent de réapparaître
et en même temps toute la déchéance,
qu'on pourrait dire, de la moralité,
même dans les valeurs qu'on trouve dans nos jours.
Et donc comment aurait pu Dieu permettre ces types de choses ?
Est-ce qu'il n'a pas la capacité d'empêcher ?
Est-ce qu'il n'est pas tout-puissant, juste, etc.
Donc non seulement dans les tragédies qu'on fait face dans nos vies,
ce sont des excuses ou des arguments que les personnes veulent présenter envers Dieu.
Si Dieu est bon, tout-puissant et il est là en train de participer de cette histoire,
pourquoi il n'a pas empêché que cette tragédie arrive à moi-même, à mes chers, etc.
Et donc là, il faut que les chrétiens connaissent bien
pour pouvoir répondre à ces questions,
particulièrement dans nos jours et particulièrement devant
cet égard scientifique prédominant
où toutes les choses sont resserrées
à l'impossibilité dans leur compréhension d'une intervention divine,
ce qui est déjà de soi-même complètement incohérent,
même avec la logique.
Car plusieurs philosophes,
et voilà pourquoi nous voyons comment l'apôtre Paul,
il a utilisé de manière très intentionnelle et très philosophique
lorsqu'il prêchait en Athènes,
en parlant qu'en lui, nous avons les mouvements et l'être.
Et donc là, c'est très intéressant,
car c'était une discussion très présente dans la philosophie classique
de chercher à expliquer non seulement l'existence,
mais aussi la subsistance,
car la plus grande crise,
ou l'une des plus grandes crises de la philosophie,
c'était les mouvements.
Car la logique,
elle exige que quelque chose pour exister
soit engendrée par quelque chose préexistante.
L'inertie ne sort pas de l'inertie par elle-même.
Il a les besoins de mouvement.
Donc Aristote va présenter la conception de la divinité
comme une nécessité philosophique,
comme étant celui qui est l'être inamovible,
celui qui ne bouge pas,
mais qui est le mouvement initial de toutes les choses.
Car si ces particules embryonnaires,
selon la théorie de l'évolution,
étaient dans un moment,
dans l'inertie avec le potentiel de devenir quelque chose,
elle ne pourrait pas sortir de cette position d'inertie potentielle
sans avoir quelque chose qui fasse un élan des mouvements.
Et donc nous,
on est devant quelque chose qui va bien au-delà de ça,
même par la logique.
On voit non seulement des mouvements,
on voit de l'ordre,
on voit des cosmos,
et tout cela demande non seulement un être
qui soit l'élan de toutes choses,
mais un être qui puisse maintenir cet équilibre parfait
qui d'autre forme serait impossible
selon même les probabilités scientifiques.
Mais bon, je ne vais pas rentrer là,
mais tant la création qu'est la providence
demande l'existence logique d'un Dieu
ou d'une divinité qui soit là.
Et voilà pourquoi les langages d'Épaule,
il est très intentionnel devant son public spécifique
qui étaient des Athéniens,
des philosophes très cultivés.
Et voilà pourquoi il utilise exprès
la conception d'existence et des mouvements
pour parler de la providence
et la manière dont Dieu établit
et pour voir la maintenance de toutes les choses.
Et donc, c'est très pertinent pour nous encore aujourd'hui
car aussi il est lié à ces mises en question
qui sont faites dans nos jours,
même envers la prière.
Donc moi, j'ai très proche de notre famille,
un membre de notre famille qui n'est pas croyant
et à chaque fois, il revient à cette question
si Dieu est souverain et omniscient,
pourquoi a-t-il besoin de nos prières ?
Et nous qui sommes croyants,
nous croyons que Dieu répond aux prières,
nous croyons que les prières
n'échangent pas la pensée de Dieu,
c'est clair, car Dieu n'a qu'un plan A,
mais Dieu a décidé que nos prières auraient l'effet.
Donc la prière A de la puissance
pour changer les choses.
Dieu a décrété que les choses qui vont se passer,
se passeront aussi à travers les contributions
des prières de son peuple.
Et donc ça, c'est une question très légitime
qu'on doit être aussi prêt à répondre.
Et donc, avant de continuer,
on a abordé la difficulté de la doctrine,
nous rappeler qu'il s'agit d'une doctrine difficile,
notamment lorsque nous nous trouvons devant notre...
C'est logiquement inévitable,
et par l'expérience humaine,
c'est inévitable d'être constamment devant
la providence des dieux,
d'arriver à la conclusion qu'il y a un dieu
qui gouverne toutes les choses.
Par contre, nous sommes très faibles
pour avoir la capacité d'interpréter correctement
la providence des dieux.
Et ça, c'est l'un des plus grands risques
pour les êtres humains.
Donc quand on pense, par exemple,
à cette tragédie qui a eu lieu
dans la période du Seigneur Jésus-Christ lui-même,
et tout de suite,
Jésus va empêcher ses disciples
d'arriver à des mauvaises conclusions.
La tour qui est tombée,
la tour des Siloën,
et l'Écrit s'il va dire,
ne pensez pas qu'il vous aide plus juste qu'eux.
OK ?
Et donc des fois,
on a cette tendance
à des manières très précipitées
de dire,
ces choses sont en train de se passer
avec ces peuples,
car c'est un peuple idolâtre,
immoral, etc.
Et c'est possible parfois
que ça soit vraiment un jugement divan.
Mais nous n'avons là pas la capacité
d'arriver à un tel type de conclusion.
Car des fois,
la lumière qui Dieu a donnée
à une nation
par rapport à la moralité,
à la christianeté, etc.,
la chrétienté,
ça fait que nous sommes
davantage rédébables devant Dieu
et parfois mériteurs
d'un jugement plus sévère
qu'il y ait certaines nations
qui sont plutôt dans l'idolâtrie,
sans accès à la lumière de l'Évangile.
Et donc c'est très important
de ne pas être précipitées,
par exemple,
pour dire qui est l'antichrist
ou quelle est la date
du retour du Christ,
des choses que la Bible
a toujours interdit de faire.
On peut être sûr
qu'on doit être vigilant,
attentif,
mais de ne jamais être précipitées
à chercher,
à expliquer les choses
ou à interpréter les choses.
Et nous avons
et nous devons reconnaître
notre limitation,
particulièrement
lorsqu'on fait face
aux tragédies personnelles
dans nos vies.
On doit être sûr
que tout contribue
à notre bien,
mais nous n'avons pas parfois
les réponses
qui seront capables
de faire les liens
entre la providence divine
et cette tragédie
ou cette injustice même
qui est commise
devant nos yeux.
Si on commence
à lire l'histoire de Joseph,
on évoque
de l'injustice
et à la fin de l'histoire,
on voit comment
tout cela
était en plan sage
des dieux
pour sauver
non seulement Joseph,
mais Israël
tout entier.
Et voilà pourquoi
on doit s'approcher
avec révérence,
reconnaissance
en mystère,
humilité
et chercher
surtout les réconforts
et la paix
qui est toutes les réponses
qu'on aurait aimé avoir
pour nos vies.
Il y a toujours un but,
mais nous ne connaissons pas
toujours les raisons
des choses qu'on traverse.
Donc c'est une doctrine
d'abord et avant tout
très explicite
dans la Bible
et la doctrine biblique,
elle nous présente
la providence
comme une conception
d'un Dieu
activement au contrôle
de toutes les choses.
Ça c'est un enseignement
clair dans la Bible,
ce qui fait
que notre conception
de la providence
s'oppose directement
et absolument
à quelques conceptions
théistes
qui ne font pas justice
à la conception biblique.
Donc à nouveau,
quelques conceptions théistes,
celles qui même
plusieurs philosophes
qui veulent
et qui étaient athées
changent des positions
pour devenir théistes
par cette nécessité
d'une cause non causée
par exemple
ou du responsable
du mouvement.
Ok ?
Et par là,
ils vont dire
non,
c'est une nécessité
d'avoir un Dieu.
Mais certains vont s'arrêter
et dire qu'ils sont plutôt
comme un horloger.
C'est quelqu'un
qui a donné les cordes
dans un horloge,
qui a un système
de fonctionnement
et il s'est abstenu.
Et ça,
ce n'est pas du tout
la position biblique.
Pour la Bible,
c'est plutôt
les capitaines
d'un navire.
C'est un Dieu
qui gouverne
tout cet univers
dans la direction
exacte
où il veut amener.
Il gouverne même
les vents,
il gouverne même
les intempéries
et toutes les choses
qui sont autour.
Ce n'est pas non plus
la providence
du panthéisme
qui va faire
que Dieu soit
un esclave
de sa propre création
et qu'il soit susceptible
au mouvement
de cette création
de cette nature
qui aurait pu changer
les cours
de l'histoire.
Donc,
Dieu n'est ni
soumis
à la création
qu'il a faite
à point
qu'il puisse
être affecté
par la conduite
des choses,
que les choses
puissent les prendre
par surprise
ou que les forces
puissent égaler
la scène
ou changer
les cours
des choses.
Donc,
Dieu n'est pas
resserré
dans une espèce
de panthéisme.
Il est séparé
de la matière.
Toutefois,
la matière
subsiste en lui
et donc,
ce n'est pas
les dieux
du panthéisme
pour plus
que Dieu
soit bien présent,
qu'il soit omniprésent
dans toute la création.
Donc,
voilà
ce qui est
l'enseignement biblique
pour ce qui concerne
la clarté
de cette doctrine
trouvée dans la Bible.
Et cette doctrine,
elle est claire
par des déclarations
directes,
qu'on a déjà vues
quelques versets,
on verra encore,
par l'effet
des prophéties.
Donc,
à nouveau,
les simples faits
que nous puissions
attester
si tant
d'accomplissement
prophétique,
c'est la preuve
qu'il est Dieu
qui a promis
et en train
de contrôler
et efficacement
mener à terme
tout ce qu'il a promis.
Donc,
les prophéties,
elles sont les preuves
de la providence.
L'effet des prières,
les prières répandues,
donc c'est clairement
la réponse
d'un Dieu
qui interagit
réellement
avec ses enfants
et qui porte
les réponses
à ses prières.
Et l'effet
des miracles aussi,
qui sont,
quelque part,
la suspension
des lois
régulières
ou des lois
secondaires
par lesquelles
Dieu gouverne
ordinairement
toutes les choses
et il peut intervenir
en suspendant
ces lois
en agissant
directement
de manière
miraculeuse.
Donc,
à partir du moment
où chez Discovery Channel
ou d'autres chaînes,
vous êtes un peu
excité
car ils arrivent
à expliquer
scientifiquement
un miracle,
vous n'êtes plus
en train
de parler
des miracles.
OK ?
Car un miracle,
par définition,
c'est plutôt
une manière
de réduire
la foi
envers les miracles
chez les chrétiens.
Et la réalité,
c'est que les miracles,
ils sont véritablement
et directement
les choses
qui vont
surmonter
et même
suspendre
les fonctionnements
naturels
des choses.
Il faut faire
une espèce
de distinction
entre ce qu'on appelle
quelques providences
extraordinaires
où les choses
peuvent converger
et Dieu fait
aux âges
des lois naturels
pour changer
les cours
sous l'histoire
ou pour porter
une délivrance
envers nos vies.
Par contre,
un miracle,
c'est vraiment
quelque chose
où Dieu va
suspendre
ses lois ordinaires
et fonctionnement
et agir directement,
intervenir
de cette manière
dans la création.
Donc,
on a défini
la doctrine
avec cette déclaration
ou comme on peut
définir
avec les paragraphes
de la confession
des fois,
la providence
est l'exercice
continu
de la puissance
divine
par laquelle
les créateurs
soutiennent
toutes ces créatures,
agissent
dans tout ce qui
se passe
dans les mondes
et dirigent
toutes choses
vers leur
fin fixé.
OK ?
Et donc,
par là,
on a trois aspects
principaux
qu'on a considérés
dans la providence.
La préservation,
c'est un Dieu
qui maintient
l'existence
de toutes les choses
et de toutes facultés
qui composent ces choses.
Donc,
quand on va dans
les cas
de Damboukou
de Nazareth,
à un moment donné,
il va suspendre
même les fonctionnements
de sa raison.
Il commence à agir
comme une bête sauvage.
Quel est l'enseignement ?
C'est que même
les fonctionnements
de nos facultés
raisonnables
ne peuvent pas
être pris par acquis
dans nos vies.
Ce sont des choses
que Dieu lui-même
entendait.
Voilà pourquoi
les sermons
de Jonathan Edward
étaient tellement puissants
car les témoignages
de ces sermons
dans les réveils,
les pécheurs
dans les mentes
d'endus en colère,
c'est que les personnes
étaient en train
de s'accrocher
même aux piliers
de l'Église
en ayant la sensation
qu'à n'importe quel moment
les sols pourraient s'ouvrir
et ils seraient avalés
par l'enfer.
Et quelle était l'emphase,
l'une des emphases
les plus accablantes
dans ces sermons,
c'est qu'il disait
que la nature elle-même
étant rendue otage
de notre condition pécheresse,
elle ne nous donne pas
la provision volontière
car c'est comme
si elle voulait résister
à nous offrir
ce qu'elle sait
qui fonctionnera
pour les mentir
de l'existence
et ceux qui feront usage
de la provision des dieux
pour se rébeller contre Dieu,
pour vivre une vie
contraire à la vie des dieux,
contraire à la piété.
Et donc,
c'est cette conviction
que Dieu dans sa grâce,
Dieu dans sa patience,
il garde la maintenance
des choses,
et nous devons être conscients
que lorsqu'il permet
que nous soyons
en train de vivre encore
par sa provision,
il est en train
dans sa patience
très élargie
de fournir
ce qui va permettre
aux hommes
de se rébeller
contre lui-même
et de pratiquer
de l'injustice.
Et donc,
c'est cette conception
de la providence divine
qui ne doit jamais
être prise par acquis
et qui sera toujours
en train de jouer
pour notre condamnation.
Vous comprenez ?
Et donc,
c'est important
de remarquer,
Dieu,
il est en train
de préserver
toutes les choses
malgré notre indignité
à cet égard.
Donc,
il y a cette notion
des mantiens
où Dieu va,
même,
comme j'ai dit
en psaume 104,
lorsque les lions
sauvent,
vont sortir
pour chasser
et que Dieu
va pourvoir
la proie pour eux.
OK ?
Donc là,
c'est un Dieu
qui soutient
toutes les choses.
c'est un Dieu-ci
qui gouverne.
Donc,
la notion
des gouvernements,
elle est aussi présente
dans la conception.
Et là,
c'est une notion
que nous allons
l'emploger
un peu plus aujourd'hui,
mais c'est une notion
de gouvernance
qui agit
par permission.
Mais là,
il faut qu'on fasse
attention avec ces mots
car on a l'impression
qu'on est en train
d'alléger les choses
ou d'érégler les choses.
C'est très important,
comme dit à Suspo,
de savoir reconnaître
que même les choses
qui Dieu permet.
On sait très bien,
ce sont des choses
qu'il aurait pu empêcher.
Il est tout puissant,
il est au contrôle
et donc,
ça n'aide pas trop
quand on essaie
d'échapper
aux questions morales
ou éthiques
quand on dit tout simplement
que ce n'est pas
sous la permission divine
car sous la permission divine
veut dire
que Dieu a
ce de reconnaître
qu'il a la capacité
d'empêcher,
de résister.
Sauf que Dieu,
dans sa sagesse,
il va gouverner
les choses
de manière
à faire
que toutes les choses
aboutissent toujours
à un bien majeur,
un bien suprême.
Et donc,
c'est intéressant,
la gouvernance des dieux,
elle est une gouvernance active
parfois par orientation.
Donc,
les agents libres
sont responsables
de leurs actions
et Dieu va faire
une orientation
de ses actions
envers les bonnes choses
de manière sainte,
sage et juste.
Et,
de l'autre côté,
c'est un dieu
qui peut gouverner
de manière directe
en intervenant parfois.
Donc,
ça va nous lancer
dans la discussion
entre,
par exemple,
les termes
dans la Bible
qui nous parlent
de la préordination
même à la perdition
et les termes
de la prédestination
qui présuppose
et qui est souvent lié
à la notion
d'intervention divine.
Donc,
lorsque nous sommes sauvés,
Dieu a besoin
d'intervenir.
Si Dieu n'intervient pas,
nous serons tous
en train de nous conduire
envers l'enfer.
sauf si Dieu intervient
par sa grâce
et nous sauve.
Par contre,
lorsque Dieu parle
de ceux qui étaient
préordonnés à l'enfer,
ce sont des agents libres
qui,
à cause de leur volonté libre
et à cause de leur corruption
et rébellion,
se conduiront naturellement,
volontairement,
dans la direction
dans laquelle
ils mériteront l'enfer.
Donc là,
j'anticipe
quelques nuances,
mais c'est pour dire
que tout est sous
la gouvernance
de Dieu.
Et là,
c'est cette reconnaissance
que même Nabucodonosor
a eue
lorsqu'il a récupéré
son intelligence
qu'il déclare
à la fin de ses jours,
Nabucodonosor
« Je lève mes yeux
vers le ciel
et mon intelligence
m'y revend.
J'ai béni les traits
aux,
je louais et j'honorais
celui qui vit éternellement
dont la domination
est éternelle
et dont les rois hommes
subsistent d'âge en âge.
Tous les habitants
de la terre
sont considérés
comme riant.
Il fait selon sa volonté
dans l'armée des cieux
et parmi les habitants
de la terre,
personne ne peut arrêter
sa mort
ni lui dire
que faites-tu. »
Donc là,
on voit clairement
que les descendants
de Dieu
s'accomplissent
car il est en train
de gouverner
toutes les choses.
Et pour mieux comprendre
cette notion
des gouvernances
inévitables
de la part de Dieu,
il y a un troisième élément
qu'on appelle,
qui se rappelle
de cet élément
l'élément
de la concurrence.
Et donc,
l'élément
de la concurrence
nous rappelle
et là,
tout comme
on retrouvera
dans les paragraphes
de la confession
des fois,
que même si Dieu
gouverne
toutes les choses
en déterminant
et en gouvernant
pour que tous
les moyens
soient les mieux
possibles
pour accomplir
les fins
les plus élevés,
c'est un Dieu
qui toutefois
ne fait pas violence
contre la volonté
de la créature.
C'est-à-dire,
nous n'avons pas
la capacité
d'harmoniser
cette vérité biblique
qui nous déclare
à la une.
Dieu est souverain
et il gouverne
activement
toutes les choses,
y compris
les facultés
des pensées
des hommes.
Et en même temps,
la Bible nous enseigne
clairement
que Dieu
a déterminé
que les choses
vont se passer
à travers
la réalité
de la libre volonté
des êtres humains.
Tous les êtres humains
sont en train
d'agir librement.
Et même
lorsque nous
nous convertissons
par la grâce de Dieu
en recevant
un nouveau cœur,
nous embrassons
l'Évangile
volontairement.
Nous avons
une nouvelle volonté
qui a été habilité,
régénérée,
mais cette volonté
nous pousse
volontairement
à aller dans la direction
des dieux
en répentance
et foi.
Et pour ceux
qui vivent
dans les péchés
et dans la rébellion,
dans la crédulité,
ils sont aussi responsables
car ils agissent
et ils vivent
librement.
Ils ont voulu
retenir la vérité,
supprimer la vérité
pour préférer
l'injustice.
C'est la question
de la corruption
du cœur.
Et donc,
c'est intéressant
de remarquer,
la concurrence
nous enseigne
que la liberté
et la responsabilité
humaine
est une réalité.
Et nous n'avons
pas la capacité
de tout comprendre,
de tout harmoniser,
mais la Bible
nous enseigne ça.
Dieu a décrété
toutes les choses
et il gouverne
activement.
Par contre,
il y a les moyens
secondaires
qui vont jouer
et sur lesquels
Dieu a son gouvernement.
c'est-à-dire,
les prières
des saints,
ce sont des prières
volontaires,
libres,
que Dieu a déterminé
d'utiliser
pour accomplir
ses planques.
La volonté
de ces créatures,
c'est la même chose.
Et donc,
vous avez tué
l'auteur de la vie.
Malheur à ces livres
par qui
les fils de l'homme
sont livrés.
Responsabilité
reconnue,
sera punie.
Les hommes ont agi
librement
lorsqu'ils ont choisi
Barabbas
au lieu de Christ.
Par contre,
ils étaient en train
de les faire
selon l'arrêt des dieux.
Les mêmes versets
nous disent ça.
Vous avez
mis à mort
les Christ
selon l'arrêt des dieux.
Selon la préscience
de très haut,
mais non selon la préscience,
selon l'arrêt,
c'est-à-dire
les décrets des dieux.
Vous comprenez ?
Donc,
les fils de l'homme
sont livrés
comme c'est écrit
à son sujet.
mais malheur
à celui
par qui
les fils de l'homme
sont livrés.
Vous comprenez ?
Ces deux choses
sont déclarées
dans la Bible
sans hésitation
pendant tout le temps.
Là,
quand on est devant
les pharaons,
on voit comment
la Bible nous dit
cinq fois
qu'il a endorci
son cœur
et cinq fois
que Dieu a endorci
les cœurs des pharaons.
Vous comprenez ?
Ces deux déclarations
sont toujours trouvées
sans aucune problématique
car là,
elles parlent
d'une perspective
ultime divine
et les moyens
secondaires
ou concourant
par lesquels
ces choses
auront lieu.
Et donc,
les problèmes,
c'est quand on essaye
de rester
dans ces extrêmes
sans prendre en compte
la symétrie biblique.
Et donc,
pour apporter
quelque chose
de nouveau aujourd'hui,
nous allons considérer
les dégrés
ou les aspects
d'exécution.
OK ?
Donc,
lorsqu'il y a
Dieu
qui va exécuter
sa providence,
nous,
les théologiens,
lorsqu'on contemple
la Bible,
on commence
à classifier
les perceptions
qui peuvent nous donner
du confort aussi
à l'égard
de la providence divine.
Et là,
on fait la distinction
entre ce qu'on appelle
la providence
générale des dieux
et la providence
spéciale des dieux.
La providence générale
des dieux,
c'est tout simplement
ce qu'on va retrouver
de manière panoramique
dans l'épisode 4
et nous verrons
que tout l'univers
est soutenu
par la parole
puissante des dieux.
Que Dieu est en train
d'avoir
une espèce
d'activité générale
où il est en train
d'activement soutenir
l'existence,
l'énergie,
la maintenance,
la gouvernance
de tout ce qui est en train
de se passer aujourd'hui
dans l'univers.
Et là,
on peut penser
à un Dieu
assez éloigné,
un Dieu parfois
calculiste et froid
et cette providence générale,
parfois,
nous devons l'admirer
énormément,
mais parfois,
on pense
que ça peut
n'est pas
impliquer
l'intérêt des dieux
envers les petits détails.
Sauf qu'il a bien
nous présente
qu'il est dieux
du macro,
de la providence
et de la gouvernance
du macro.
C'est aussi
un dieu
qui est en train
de gouverner
les macros
par la gouvernance
du micro,
de chaque particule
atomique,
si vous voulez,
dans n'importe quel
moindre endroit
de l'univers.
Donc,
c'est les dieux
qui gouvernent
les planètes
par la gouvernance
de chaque particule
atomique
qui compose
chacun
de ces planètes.
et donc,
c'est intéressant
de remarquer ici,
la providence générale,
c'est cet enseignement
biblique tout simplement
qui est dieu
en train de contrôler
l'univers
et maintenir
et le fonctionnement
des grandes lois
qui existent.
En même temps,
on classifie aussi
ce qu'on appelle
la providence spéciale.
Et donc,
tout d'abord,
c'est ces soins
des dieux particuliers
sur chaque être
et chaque créature,
même les psaumes 104
réviant
sur cette préoccupation
envers chaque animal,
envers qui Dieu pourvoit.
Voilà pourquoi
la Bible nous dit aussi
qu'il est juste
traite bien les animaux.
Mais c'est intéressant
de remarquer,
les soins des dieux
envers sa création
en prennent soin
particulièrement
de chaque portion
de sa création.
En même temps,
la providence spéciale,
elle est particulièrement
manifestée
sur les êtres humains,
l'image des dieux.
On sait que toute la providence,
elle était quelque part
en train de tourner
autour des êtres humains
dans la création.
Et ça continue
malgré la rébellion humaine.
En Matthieu 5,
3, 45,
le Seigneur Jésus
l'enseigne en disant
« Vous avez appris
ce qui a été dit,
tu aimeras ton prochain,
tu haïras ton ennemi,
mais moi je vous dis
aimez vos ennemis,
bénissez ceux
qui vous maudissent,
faites du bien
à ceux qui vous haïssent
et priez pour ceux
qui vous maltraitent
et qui vous persécutent
afin que vous soyez
fils de votre Père
qui est dans les cieux,
car il fait lever son soleil
sur les méchants
et sur les bons
et il fait pleuvoir
sur les justes
et sur les injustes. »
Donc, dans sa grâce,
dans sa condescendance,
dans son amour général
envers les êtres humains,
Dieu pourvoit
les soleils,
Dieu pourvoit la pluie
aux justes et aux injustes.
Donc là,
il y a un intérêt
des dieux particuliers
pour la race humaine,
pour les mentiens
de la race humaine,
ce qu'on va voir même
après les déluges
avec la promesse
de ne plus détruire
l'univers de la même manière,
mais de manière particulière aussi,
ce qu'on peut appeler
parfois la grâce commune
qui va toucher aussi
aux bonnes choses
que Dieu permet
qui se passent
dans l'humanité.
Donc, c'est un dieux
qui pourvoit
de manière spéciale
aux mentiens
et l'épanouissement
de la race humaine.
Mais c'est aussi intéressant
de remarquer
qu'il y a
un soin tout spécial
des dieux
envers son peuple,
envers son église.
Et donc là,
c'est l'une des vérités
les plus réconfortantes
qu'on va considérer,
c'est ces soins
des dieux particuliers
envers son église.
Et donc,
comment nous pouvons trouver
ces évidences
dans la parole des dieux ?
Donc, je vais vous citer
quelques références
ou quelques textes.
Donc, la providence
des dieux
dans un premier moment
s'exerce
sur tout l'univers.
L'Epsom 103,
19 nous dit
« L'Éternel a établi
son trône dans les cieux
et son règne
domine sur tout. »
OK ?
En deuxième lieu,
elle s'exerce aussi
d'une manière
particulière
sur les mondes physiques.
Donc, l'Epsom 104
qui nous montre
tous les détails
qu'on a déjà évoqués
et cette préoccupation
avec l'humanité aussi
qu'on a déjà citée
des Matthieu 145.
Donc, cette gouvernance
des dieux,
même sur la pluie,
sur le soleil,
etc.
Tous les animaux
sont concernés
quand on revient
à l'Epsom 104
et même ses sermons
contre l'anxiété
du Christ
en Matthieu 6
lorsqu'il va parler
par exemple
« Les oiseaux du cieux
qui n'essaient
ni maçonnent,
qui n'amassent rien
dans les greniers
et notre Père Céleste
les nourrit.
Ok ? »
Et même par rapport
aux moineux,
c'est intéressant,
« Ne vendons pas
deux passereux
par en dessous,
cependant,
pas un d'eux
ne tombe à terre
sans la volonté
de votre Père. »
Donc, dans des particularités
même du soin
d'un petit oiseau,
nous voyons
de manière très claire
cette providence divine.
La quatrième place,
les affaires des nations,
donc même les enjeux
des business
entre les nations
ou les enjeux politiques.
Job 12, 24,
il enlève les cœurs
des chefs
des peuples
de la terre
et il les fait
errer dans un désert
où il y a
point de chemin
ou un acte 17
où Paul va parler
sur ça.
Il l'a fait
au verset 26,
« D'un seul
toutes les nations
des hommes
pour qu'ils y habitent
sur toute la face
de la terre
ayant fixé
des temps déterminés
et les bornes
de leur demeure. »
Donc, quand est-ce
et comment
l'empire romant
va s'élever,
quand est-ce
qu'il va tomber
et quand est-ce
qu'il sera limité.
Quelle sera
la prochaine nation
qui montera
à l'évidence
et qui ensuite,
combien de temps
va durer
cet empire,
cette influence
et quand est-ce
que ça va tomber.
Donc, toutes ces choses,
Dieu a fixé
et il est activement
en train
de gouverner
pour que ces choses
montent
ou tombent.
Comme l'Écrit
l'a dit à Pilate,
aucune autorité
n'était serrée donnée
si du haut
elle ne serait donnée
ou accordée.
Et donc là,
la providence
en cinquième aspect,
c'est la manière
dont Dieu gouverne
sur la naissance
et la destinée
d'un homme individuel
dans ces mondes.
Donc, nos jours
sont comptés.
1 Samuel 16,
il dit,
l'Éternel dit à Samuel,
jusqu'à quand pleureras-tu
sur Saül
puisque je l'ai rejeté
pour qu'il ne règne
plus sur Israël,
remplis ta corne d'huile
et va,
je t'envoie vers Isaïe,
les Bethléemites
car j'ai choisi pour moi
un roi parmi ses fils.
Donc là,
Dieu avait déjà déterminé
la fin de l'or
de Saül.
Et ensuite,
en Galate 1,
15 et 16,
mais quand il a plu à Dieu
qui m'avait mis à part
dès les ventes de ma mère
et qui m'avait appelé
par sa grâce
de révéler son fils en moi
afin que j'ai l'annonce
parmi les nations.
Donc,
tous les jours
de l'apôtre Paul
ont été comptés.
Dieu avait déjà un but
pour sa vie
depuis son ventre maternel
jusqu'au moment
où il avait décidé
que tout son passé
allait jouer
pour l'accomplissement
de sa vie
après sa conversion.
Donc,
toutes les choses
qui ont pu être
ré-signifiées,
toutes les choses
qui ne pouvaient pas
être perdues,
tous les traumas,
même de permettre
que Paul soit celui
qui va persécuter
les chrétiens,
tout cela a joué
grandement
pour qu'il devienne
le monument
de la grâce de Dieu
qu'il a devenu.
Et Paul avait
cette compréhension
qu'il était mis à part
dès les vents de sa mère.
Le sixième aspect,
c'est la providence
de Dieu
sur les succès
et échecs
de la vie humaine.
La promotion
ne vient ni de l'Orient
ni de l'Occident
ni du désert,
mais c'est Dieu
qui juge,
il abaisse les uns,
il élève les autres.
Psaume 75,
6 et 7.
Dieu gouverne même
sur ce qui a l'apparence
d'être accidentel
ou insignifiant.
Donc,
on pourrait considérer
Esther
dans les chapitres 6,
si j'ai bien noté
la référence,
mais c'est intéressant
de remarquer
comment,
dans cette nuit-là,
les rois
ne pouvaient pas dormir.
Il n'a aucune explication
pourquoi ces rois
ne pourraient pas dormir.
Quelqu'un pourrait dire
cela n'a sûrement
rien à voir
avec la providence
des dieux,
mais lorsqu'on lit
les livres d'Esther,
on va voir
que c'est un point crucial,
crucial.
lorsqu'il n'arrive pas
à dormir,
car Dieu l'empêchait
et c'est par là
qu'Emardoché
a pu être sauvé
car il a pris
la considération
en lisant la parole
des dieux
de ces enregistrements
qui étaient faits,
les documents royaux,
pardon,
de ces enregistrements
qui étaient faits.
Donc,
c'était une insomnie
qui a fini
pour sauver
les peuples des dieux.
Et on pourrait même
citer Proverbe 16,
33,
on jette les sorts
dans les pommes
de vêtements,
mais toute décision
vient de l'éternel.
C'est comme si
on était en train
de jeter en dé
en pensant
que nous sommes
en train de faire
la chose
la plus aléatoire
possible,
mais en réalité,
c'est Dieu
qui détermine
les résultats
et il les connaît
déjà.
Non seulement
il l'a décrété,
mais il est en train
de conduire
pour que ça
tombe dans un certain
doigt.
l'huitième aspect,
c'est que la providence
des dieux
protège particulièrement
les justes.
Le psaume 4,
8 dit
« Je m'écouche
et je m'endors
en paix
car toi seul
au éternel,
tu me fais
habiter
en sécurité. »
Et donc là,
lorsqu'un chrétien
fait face
au manque de sommeil,
à l'insomnie,
à l'anxiété,
à la panique,
il faut qu'il s'y rappelle
qu'il peut
se reposer
car la providence
des dieux
protège particulièrement
son peuple.
Le neuvième aspect,
Dieu pourvoir
aux besoins
de son peuple
par sa providence.
Philippiens 4,
19,
qui nous sommes
en train de considérer,
qui dit
« Mon Dieu pourvoir
à tous vos besoins
selon sa richesse
avec gloire
en Jésus-Christ. »
Le dixième aspect,
ce sont les réponses
des prières
qu'on trouve
dans les Écritures.
Dieu qui répond
aux prières
de son peuple.
C'est important
toujours quand on pense
à la prière.
de nous rappeler
que lorsque la Bible
nous présente
la prière du juste,
quelle est l'expression
française ?
J'essaie de traduire
des mémoires.
Elle a une grande efficacité
où,
d'une manière plus littérale,
elle porte beaucoup
sur l'efficacité.
Ça,
ce n'est pas une assurance
que toutes les prières
seront répondues,
il n'y a aucune assurance
à cet égard,
selon la manière
qui ont pris.
Car la sagesse de Dieu
est là,
vraiment,
c'est décret.
Et donc,
nous devons prier
avec ferveur
car c'est un élément
qu'on trouve
dans ce même passage.
La prière fervente,
on peut dire comme ça,
ou la prière
fervente,
oui,
de juste,
a beaucoup
d'implications
sur ses effets.
Donc,
ce n'est pas une assurance
que toutes les prières
seront répondues
selon notre terme,
mais elles portent
beaucoup d'efficacité,
beaucoup d'impact
dans les choses
qui se passent.
Donc,
on doit prier toujours
avec cette conviction.
Et en même temps,
on voit comment
ce n'est que la providence
de Dieu
qui peut expliquer
les prophéties
et les miracles.
Donc,
on a tous ces aspects
qui parlent
de la providence
spéciale des dieux,
mais il y a aussi
quelques aspects
difficiles
de la doctrine.
Et donc,
j'aimerais qu'on considère
maintenant
quelques questions
qui sont posées.
Donc,
la première,
c'est cette notion
que Dieu
étant si grand
et devant
prendre soin
d'un univers
si grand,
ça serait
difficile
pour nous
d'imaginer
qu'il pourrait être
troublé
ou préoccupé
par des détails
très insignifiants
à propos
de ma propre vie.
Et c'est vraiment
le contraire
que Dieu présente.
Nez vous inquiéter
de rien,
Philippe 1, 4, 6,
mais en toutes choses,
faites connaître
vos désirs
ou vos besoins
à Dieu
par des prières
et des supplications
avec action des grâces.
Donc,
c'est très thérapeutique
pour nous
de savoir
que Dieu compte
les cheveux
de notre tête,
qu'il prend soin
de nous
dans les détails
et qu'il est intéressé
à connaître
tous nos désirs
et nos besoins.
C'est un Dieu
très intéressé
par rapport aux détails
et parfois,
nous n'avons pas
certaines prières répondues
comme dit Calvin,
Dieu qui aime bien
les temps de communion
avec ses enfants.
Calvin,
il dit
que la prière,
c'est comme
les bras étendus
des enfants de Dieu
pour recevoir
des séments
qu'il a déjà
voulu nous donner
et nous bénir
et qu'il a
en réserve
pour nous.
Donc,
c'est comme
si on était juste
en train d'étendre
les bras
pour recevoir.
et des fois,
on ne voit pas
les réponses
des prières
quand on n'est pas
spécifique
dans nos prières.
OK ?
Ensuite,
certaines personnes
disent que
voilà,
les lois
de la nature
parfois
rendent impossible
une intervention
divine
et en même temps,
la Bible,
elle est très claire
en nous montrant
plusieurs miracles
où Dieu
a intervenu
et va suspendre
aussi ses lois
pour opérer
ces miracles.
Et la plus grande
difficulté
de la doctrine,
c'est bien sûr
les problèmes
du mal
ou de l'injustice
dans les mondes.
Et donc,
la manière
de répondre
à cette question,
c'est d'abord
de nous rappeler
que les actes
pécheurs
sont tous
sous les contrôles
divants
et ils ne peuvent
qu'y produire
ce que Dieu
dans sa sagesse
et dans son
descent ultime
a décrété.
Et donc,
à nouveau,
un exemple clair,
c'est celui
de Joseph.
Ce n'est donc pas
vous
qui m'avez envoyé
ici
lorsque ses frères
l'ont vendu
comme esclave,
mais c'est Dieu.
Et donc,
Dieu,
il a permis,
il a gouverné
l'acte injuste
de ses hommes
afin de conduire
la vie de Joseph
par l'école exacte
qu'il avait planifiée
de Joseph,
afin qu'il puisse
grandir en maturité,
constater que son bien
souverain
était Christ lui-même
pendant tous les parcours
et afin de mettre
Joseph dans une position
de contrôle
car à chaque fois,
ses vertus,
son intégrité
ont été attestées
dans les contextes
où il a souffert
l'injustice.
Et donc,
ici,
c'est intéressant,
on voit de manière
très claire
comment les actes
pécheurs
sont saoulés
contre le divan.
Il faut toujours
commencer
par la considération
de ce que la Bible
nous présente
comme les plus clairs.
Dieu nous est présenté
comme celui
qui ne peut même pas
contempler les mals
et qui ne peut
tenter personne.
Et lorsque la Bible
nous donne des enseignements
en parlant
que Dieu est très sain,
que Dieu est bon,
que les choses
plus compliquées
pour nous à comprendre
ne prennent jamais
l'avance
sur les choses
qui sont clairement
communiquées
dans la parole
de Dieu.
Ça,
c'est un bon ordre aussi
pour traiter
des sujets difficiles.
En acte 2,
j'ai déjà cité
ces passages,
mais nous voyons
au verset 22,
« Oh miséralite,
écoutez ces paroles,
Jésus des Nazarètes,
cet homme à qui
Dieu a rendu témoignage
devant vous
par les miracles,
les prodiges
et les signes
qu'il a opérés
par lui
au milieu de vous,
comme vous le savez
vous-même,
cet homme livré
selon les desseins
arrêté et selon
la préscience
de Dieu,
vous l'avez crucifié,
vous l'avez fait
mourir par les
mans des empies,
par les mans des empies.
Dieu l'a ressuscité
en les délivrant
des liens de la mort
parce qu'il n'était
pas possible
qu'ils furent étenus
par la mort. »
Et donc,
quand on a cette question,
pourquoi Dieu permet
que des mauvaises choses
arrivent à des personnes
innocentes,
il y a cette réponse
classique des assistés
qui dit toujours,
cela n'est jamais arrivé,
cela n'est qu'arrivé
une seule fois
et la personne
qui a subi
à l'injustice
l'a subi
de manière volontaire,
c'était à Christ.
Aucune chose
ne peut se passer
à aucun d'entre nous
dans cette vie
qui puisse être comparable
à ce qu'on mérite
souffrir
et ce que nous sommes
destinés à souffrir
pendant toute l'éternité
à l'enfer.
Nous ne trouvons
aucun juste
dans toute l'humanité
et même si certaines personnes
pratiquent des actes
d'injustice
contre nous,
nous pouvons être
injusticés selon
les paramètres des hommes,
par contre,
aucune souffrance
qu'on subit
ne peut être comparable
à ce qu'on mérite
souffrir à l'enfer.
On commence par là,
en nous remettant
dans notre position.
Par contre,
si nous sommes exposés
à plusieurs absurds
dans cette vie,
les abus
que les enfants
peuvent souffrir,
les guerres
qui finissent
pour tuer des personnes
qui sont innocentes
au moment
dans la question
de la guerre,
dans la situation
de la guerre
ou toutes ces attaques
terroristes
qu'on voit
où les personnes
sont en train
de souffrir
de l'injustice,
toutes ces choses
sont des absurds
qui vont retrouver
dans l'absurde
de la croix,
comme dit
John Stott,
sont des absurdifications.
J'explique.
C'est-à-dire,
lorsque nous
nous sentons
devant
une perplexité,
nous devons
être amenés
à contempler la croix
et à la croix
trouver la plus grande
de toutes les perplexités.
Car là-bas,
on va au moins
être sûr
que Dieu ne joue pas
avec nos sentiments.
On va être sûr
que Dieu connaît
la pire des douleurs,
la douleur
de voir son propre fils
mourir
et souffrir
les pires des abus.
Dans son livre,
Stott,
il va dire
plus ou moins comme ça,
quelqu'un arrive
et dire
est-ce que Dieu connaît
la douleur
d'être un paralytique ?
Et on contemple la croix
et on va un Christ
crucifié,
complètement accroché
avec tous ses membres
paralysés.
Est-ce qu'on voit
quelqu'un souffrir
l'abus,
l'abus moral
et même
un abus
quelque part
qui s'approche
de la notion
sexuelle
en étant dénudé
publiquement,
en souffrant
la violence
à cet égard,
à ces points ?
Et quand on considère
le fait qu'il était
le seul être juste,
le seul être pur,
l'être le plus pur
de l'univers,
Dieu lui-même,
Dieu va apporter
par la perplexité
de la croix
la désabsurdification
de toute autre souffrance
que les êtres humains
puissent traverser
dans la vie.
Et lui,
il est en train
de donner son fils
pour soublier
toutes ces injustices
et la pire des injustices
car volontairement,
Dieu veut pourvoir
un moyen
de nous tirer
de ce qu'on mérite.
Et donc,
c'est par la considération
de cette provision divine
qui nous trouvons à la croix,
que même si nous ne pouvons
pas facilement surmonter
les absurdes
et les injustices
qu'on voit dans cette vie,
on reconnaît la perplexité,
mais nous sommes sûrs
que Dieu n'est pas en train
de jouer avec nos sentiments
et Dieu est toujours
en train de permettre
que les choses
qui sont les conséquences
qui nous méritons
de pécher
se passent
dans un monde échoué.
Donc,
dans ces mondes échoués,
Dieu nous rappelle
par les injustices
que nous devons aspirer
pour un monde
complètement restauré.
Et toute cette punition
et ces règlements
des comptes
a eu lieu
une fois à la croix
pour l'avantage
des croyants
et aura lieu
à nouveau
d'une fois définitive
à la fin des temps.
Dieu ne laisse
aucun péché impuni
et Dieu,
en Christ,
il arrive à pourvoir
la réconciliation
et toutes les choses.
Et donc,
c'est important
lorsqu'on est devant
ces perplexités
de nous rappeler
que je ne peux pas
avoir la capacité
de discerner
comment cet épisode
est en train
de jouer
pour les ailes
des dieux lui-même
envers sa propre gloire.
Je n'arrive pas
à voir comment
dans sa sagesse,
cette petite pièce
de ces mosaïques
glorieux
qui a l'histoire
va composer
l'affichage
de la beauté
de la gloire
de la sainteté
de Dieu
et de sa sagesse.
Mais je peux être sûr
que toutes les choses
sont en train
de concourir
au bien
du peuple de Dieu,
sont en train
de concourir
au bien
de la manifestation
de la gloire
de Dieu,
de la sagesse
car la remontée
la plus extraordinaire
en termes
d'injustice commise
et manifestation
de la sainteté
de Dieu,
c'est la croix
du Christ.
Nous sommes devant
la pire
de toutes les injustices
dans toute l'histoire
et Dieu est en train
de faire usage
de cette injustice
pour promouvoir
la justification,
la sainteté
de Dieu
étant affichée
par les Christ
pas cardiaux à la croix.
Donc là,
on voit de manière
très claire
la sainteté
de Dieu,
la beauté
la sagesse
de Dieu,
la provision
de Dieu
affichée
par la croix
du Christ.
Donc là,
Dieu,
il gouverne,
il renverse
les péchés
pour en tirer
du bien.
Genèse 50,
verset 20,
vous aviez médité
de faire les mals,
Dieu l'a changé
en bien
pour accomplir
ce qui arrive
aujourd'hui
pour sauver
la vie
à un peuple
nombreux.
Dieu ne cause
jamais les péchés,
il ne l'approuve,
il ne fait
qu'il les permettre
de les diriger,
de les restreindre,
de les limiter
et de les renverser
en bien.
L'homme seul
est responsable
de son péché.
Jacques,
en 12 à 15,
heureux l'homme
qui supporte
patiemment la tentation
car après avoir
été prouvé,
il recevra
la couronne des vies
que les seigneurs
a promis
à ceux qui l'aiment
que personne
lorsqu'il est tenté
ne dise
c'est Dieu
qui m'a tenté
car Dieu
ne peut être
tenté par les mals
et il ne tente
lui-même personne.
Mais chacun
est tenté
quand il est attiré
et amorcé
par sa propre
convoitise
puis la convoitise
lorsqu'il a conçu
enfante les péchés
et les péchés
étant consommés
produits
d'amour.
Donc Dieu
lorsqu'il devrait
et qu'il pourrait
déverser
toute sa colère
contre l'humanité
il a dévié
cette juste colère
de nous
envers soi-même
dans la personne
de son fils.
Et ça
c'est l'acte
suprême
des providences divines
et c'est
l'acte
suprême
de nous permettre
de mettre
en perspective
de quelle manière
Dieu gouverne
toutes les choses.
L'acte
le plus injuste
Dieu
l'a tourné
en bien
pour notre salut.
Et donc
nous allons
nous arrêter
ici aujourd'hui
en ayant traité
les difficultés
et ce qui nous restera
à traiter
pour la prochaine fois
ce sont
les aspects
les plus
réconfortants
de cette doctrine
que nous allons
considérer
pour conclure
cette étude
sur la providence.
de cette doctrine